what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the final part of dark
ages i know this is supposed to go up
yesterday but i was super distracted
working on stuff around the house so uh
we pick up basically with how it is that
miles morales became like the apocalypse
symbiote essentially is what i'm calling
it by the apocalypse it's still a cool
idea but what miles says is that shortly
after the power went out somewhere along
the line he and venom basically found
each other and he ended up basically
becoming the new venom but then they
ended up being merged or found
themselves merged with carnage now a lot
of this we don't find out how that
happened and this is one of the reasons
why i say the comic kind of felt rushed
right because if this was like a 12
issue series we would have certainly
gotten that we probably would have
gotten a singular issue devoted to how
it is that miles ended up merging with
both venom and card so i'll leave it to
you guys to decide whether or not that's
a part of the story that you felt was
necessary because some people just may
be like yeah it wasn't really necessary
at all i will say miles morales with the
the venom symbiote looks great like it
looks absolutely amazing and i love it
but the idea is that once carnage merged
with the venom symbiote and miles that
seemingly they started going off the
rails and they were just whispering
things into the ear of miles morales and
he basically lost himself now again
that's an important distinction because
that's really tom taylor kind of
grabbing a bit of the symbiote history
and bringing it in especially when it
comes to somebody like eddie brock right
eddie brock had a shared hatred for
peter parker and the venom symbiote had
a shared hatred as well so in that way
they were able to bond with each other
and use that shared hatred to basically
further their own schemes with carnage
bonding itself to cletus cassidy it was
two levels of insanity but one of the
things also remember is that one the
carnage symbiote was effectively brand
new and it didn't go insane until it
bonded itself to cletus cassidy the
other part of this is that there is a
what if story out there based on secret
wars where if a symbiote bonds with its
house long enough one the host will lose
itself and two the symbiote would kill
the host which is why in the secret wars
what if story the peter parker was
basically dead and the simeon was just
walking around using his bones it quite
literally devoured peter and so it's one
of those things where dr doom asked the
question like why would symbiotes work
for apocalypse the symbiotes themselves
by and large have their own schemes and
their own motivations and the response
of miles is because of what he planned
and what he told them the reality here
is that in order to gain the favor of
the symbiotes which as apocalypse knew
could avoid the detection of spider-man
and with spider-man spider-sense being
an early alert system would basically
allow the symbiotes to gain the upper
hand in a moment when it was absolutely
necessary presumably a different moment
outside of the one that we saw that what
what ended up happening here is
apocalypse 1 told the symbiotes what his
plan was and the symbiotes were just
kind of like okay this is a problem but
he promised the symbiotes a ship a way
to get off the planet because remember
the simians themselves are not they're
not original to earth earth is not their
home they're space faring right they
come from the stars uh technically they
come from null and then ultimately
formed a planet of their own but
regardless like they they really meant
for space itself so in their mind it was
going home it was going back to where
they're supposed to be as opposed to
being stuck on earth and that was really
or at least seemed to be enough logic on
behalf of the symbiotes that they
ultimately ended up bonding themselves
to miles morales and working directly
for apocalypse of course again miles
basically lost himself because the
reality is that miles didn't necessarily
have the willpower to overcome both the
venom and the carnage symbiote and
control them both and in fact i would
surmise very few people would i think
even peter parker would struggle under
those circumstances right like two
symbiotes with a will of their own
bonding to a singular host and then
conflicting with each other like that
would create all kinds of turmoil but
switching over to apocalypse one of the
things that we find out is that tony
stark having captain america's shield on
hand basically meant that as he was
going through all these different metals
that could be used to withstand the
rigors of a constant emp as well as the
force of the unmaker that none of them
really seemed to be able to handle it
right vibranium didn't work carbonadium
didn't work none of those things worked
but what he needed was the absolute
strongest metal in existence which is
captain america's shield captain
america's shield in marvel comics is the
strongest metal that exists in the
marvel universe adamantium comes in at a
close second and then after that you get
varying degrees of adamantium and then
you get vibranium and you get anti-metal
carbonation different things like that
but ultimately captain america shield is
at the top and what tony stark reveals
here is that building a kind of
protective layer a protective sphere
needed to have the hardest metals
possible in order to ensure the
protection of apocalypse won against the
power of the unmaker and then two to
also have the ability to exercise his
powers to control the unmaker right so
basically to create a way out but
eliminate a way in is essentially what
apocalypse was wanting to do and that's
one of the things they talk about here
tony stark says in order for me to pull
this off fully i need adamantium the
problem is adamantium isn't being made
anymore right the recipe for adamantium
is long since gone and even those who
did happen to know what that recipe is
they're dead right meyer mclean's gone
anybody who could possibly deal with
this adamantium they're gone right like
i need adamantium from somewhere and
that's when apocalypse is like we have
adamantium buried underneath us and it's
it's interesting to see tom taylor do
this because what he does is he reveals
that he has wolverine in a prison under
the entire bunker with seemingly no
means of escape now how it is that
wolverine can't escape from this place i
don't know i have no earthly clue i
doubt there's a single prison on the
face of the planet that wolverine could
not escape from especially when he's
just in the core of the earth or or down
below the earth somewhere you'd think
he'd just be able to dig his way out but
what apocalypse does is he teleports
down there with cyclops and with the
purple man and then of course where
cyclops is like they can't do this
wolverine you can't let them let me kill
you know make me kill you you can't let
that happen where wolverine tries to
jump in ultimately the purple man steps
in removes the visor and says open your
eyes and that enough is to basically
obliterate the entire just body
structure of wolverine now here's the
cool thing and it's what i love about
the way that tom taylor plays this
because wolverine's healing factor has
been just ridiculously inconsistent over
the years it's just it's nuts literally
wolverine's healing factor is a plot
device do we need wolverine out of the
picture for a little while so we can
focus on the other characters well his
healing factor is you know normal it's a
little slow do we need wolverine back
right now but we want the shock value of
him being just obliterated by someone
his healing factor is just super fast
right it really is just ridiculously
inconsistent the way that marvel handles
it but ultimately cyclops his concussive
blaster enough to just completely
eliminate the skin and and sinew and
everything off of wolverine leaving
nothing other than his skeleton and then
at that point the head is removed now
again this is one of those weird
situations where tom taylor's just kind
of rolling with it and the reason why is
because they're in in the 1990s marvel
had something called the xavier
protocols and the xavier protocols were
basically they're exactly what you think
they were they were a series of
protocols developed by charles xavier of
the x-men in order to defeat or
incapacitate or even kill members of the
of the x-men should one of them be
captured or go awry or something like
that right like in the instance that uh
cyclops is taken by the purple man or
wolverine is controlled by somebody else
or whatever and so what he said is the
only way to really kill wolverine is to
cut his head off the biggest problem
with that is you can't just cut
adamantium it requires something
ridiculously durable or something equal
to adamantium in order to pull it off or
perhaps just some kind of a celestial
blade or magic or something along those
lines but not any real conventional
weaponry apocalypse somehow managed to
do it and it could simply just be
because of his power right that it's
just tom taylor's like that's how
powerful apocalypse is and that's it we
don't really get an answer the super
hardcore comic book fan in me that like
needs continuity is like there has to be
an explanation to this but the more
mature part of me that's growing up over
the years is just kind of like that's
the nature of comics yeah it's just the
way things go and just kind of call it a
day but regardless of course the
questions asked by tony stark now that
you have your adamantium how long is
this going to take and he's like well
reed has a molecular deconstructor that
can basically break down adamantium and
that'll be it now that's not unheard of
in marvel comics right because i imagine
a lot of people who are unfamiliar with
marvel are like this is just nothing but
a series of plot devices that's not true
so like anti-metal for example arctic
vibranium that's capable of breaking
down metals including adamantium that's
one of the things that makes it so
potent and it's one of the things that
makes it so sought after that there's
actually much less arctic vibranium than
there is traditional vibranium but
getting your hands on is a very
difficult thing to do but ultimately of
course once uh tony stark gets to work
on this you end up having this
conversation between doctor octopus and
apocalypse and what octopus says here is
that with everything tony stark is doing
ultimately this should all work he says
but there's one very big hole in this
plant and he says if you move your mind
into the unmaker i can't guarantee your
current powers would work you may not be
able to teleport out the only way for
you would be to break the planet apart
and the response of of apocalypse is
yeah and what's the problem with that
and of course the response of
of octopus is like that's the planet
we're standing on and then apocalypse is
like you do have a really clever point
otto and he's like i can't have someone
that's that intelligent figuring out
what it is that i'm doing and then
telling everybody else and when he does
that he kills dr octopus because octopus
figured out pretty quickly that
apocalypse is going to end up destroying
the world that he doesn't really care
about the fact that he's destroying the
world because for someone like
apocalypse who's looking to harness the
power of a cosmic entity what is a
single world a universe that's massive
in scale that might as well be
infinitely expansive for 99 of the
universe's inhabitants right you know i
mean what does it matter because keep in
mind while this story is going on here
on earth the she are still doing their
thing and the cree and the scrolls and
the badoon and all those races are all
still out there doing their things right
for them they have no knowledge that
this has happened on earth right things
just continue on as they always have but
in the midst of all this of course once
the superheroes basically arrive in
paris there's a few things that go on
one for for may and for danny right the
daughter of peter parker and the
daughter of jessica jones and luke cage
they're too young to be able to
accompany them on this trip right it'll
just be too dangerous and if anything
bringing their children along could
create a circumstance where apocalypse
could use them as bargaining chips right
capture the kids of peter parker and
then peter will do anything or at least
capture the daughter of peter parker and
he'll do anything to save her right even
if it means turning against his allies
like he'll he'll do whatever it takes to
save his daughter and so ultimately of
course uh devil dinosaur is forced to
stay back and keep an eye on him and
he's like really man like i'm a dinosaur
like i want to i want to be where the
action is right i want to attack things
although he is injured so it is probably
in his best interest to stay there and
keep an eye on things i do love devil
dinosaur he is one of the cooler
characters that exists out there but of
course at that point once storm comes
busting in and the the fight begins one
thing that i want to point out here is
this ends like that like the ending just
seemingly comes out of nowhere which
again is one of the reasons why this
story felt so rushed that like this
whole fight probably could have been a
couple of issues right but at the end of
the day we got what we got and so what
ends up going on here is that uh of
course kilgrave isn't instructed by
apocalypse let everybody out of their
cells and with all of them operating
under the control of kilgrain there's
not a whole lot you can do and of course
you end up finding out that captain
america she hulk beast carol danvers
like all these people are here dracula
you know again cyclops and psylocke and
so on with psylocke it is a little
intriguing here because psylocke is one
of the most powerful telepaths in marvel
comics and by and large it's pretty much
always been confirmed a telepath can
overcome the power of the purple man but
this may be one of those instances where
purple man was able to ensnare her
before she realized what was going on
and then shut off her telepathic
abilities or basically she can't really
use her telepathic abilities against him
because he literally in ram them right
he went around her telepathic abilities
and there's not much she can do right by
and large she's trying to fight an enemy
she can't see so to speak i don't really
know exactly how tom taylor makes that
work but he does but at the end of the
day what's really going on here and this
is where dr doom really steps up is that
susan storm's like what do we do right
because we're going to end up having to
fight our own friends and the response
of doom is this changes nothing right
more important than the lives of our
friends is the destruction of apocalypse
and saving the world your friends would
agree and if the roles were shifted they
would attack you too it's just the
nature of things it's what we have to do
but dr doom has had a plan in the
background this entire time and this is
a cool thing because what he ends up
doing in the midst of this fight is he
pulls dracula aside and he's like
dracula we have to talk in that moment
deadpool shoots purple man
he shoots him in the head right hey
gabby's like wade you know and then
ultimately he's like he's like what like
you know i didn't what like i didn't
hear like the plan i was driving the bus
you know which you guys really raised a
good question how does the bus drive
when there's no electricity in the world
i don't know it's deadpool man just
whatever who cares it doesn't even
matter right it's deadpool driving a bus
and defying any logic or reason it
doesn't matter like it's just the way it
is
but ultimately like jessica jones was
supposed to knock him unconscious and in
the end deadpool's like oh man dude i'm
sorry jess i probably robbed you of some
much-needed catharsis here uh like do
you want to kick kick his corpse or
something
which is a really funny moment here i
absolutely love that moment between the
two of them the exchange but nonetheless
what is up going on here and again this
is where things get a little a little
strange where the ending kind of comes
in out of nowhere is that with purple
man destroyed of course now everything
is against apocalypse it's literally him
by himself and apocalypse at that point
it's just like that's fine it doesn't
matter right like thank you for your
part in in my evolution you've done your
job you know i can finish it from here
and the reality is he can and that's
that's one of the this is one of the
things
that people tend to forget about
apocalypse because you never really see
marvel comics utilizing apocalypse as he
really is right you usually see
apocalypse being utilized for like his
intelligence or like during jonathan
hickman's uh x-men run which is
something i was really hoping to see we
only got to see it once when he fought
nimrod but i was wanting to see like the
full might of apocalypse this guy would
demolish everyone here and and it
wouldn't even be hard it would not even
be difficult the only one who'd probably
be able to survive this might be
deadpool and just because of his healing
factor but everybody else no all
apocalypse has to do is grow to like
2000 feet tall and just let off these
energy beams with every ounce of
strength that he has and annihilate them
all or use his telekinesis to tear their
bodies apart or rearrange the molecular
structure of their bodies or or any
number of things right just any number
of things that he can do but where he
goes to use his power and this is a
really really interesting thing here the
way that tom taylor does this where he
goes to use his power to destroy
everybody susan storm shuts off his
access to his ability she literally puts
a kind of force field around the part of
his brain that allows him to use his
powers now here's one of the things
right this seems like a plot device and
it's not and this was actually something
that was established over the years in
susan storm's uh publications in marvel
comics but especially during jonathan
hickman's fantastic four run because one
of the things that was laid out there is
that the nuance with which susan storm
can control her force fields is
incredible she can do it on just these
exceedingly small levels like around a
portion of your brain or she can create
force fields strong enough to withstand
the power of celestials she can do a lot
she is way more powerful than people
think and in reality man people sleep on
the power of susan storm like they they
really underestimate how capable she is
which is why i say when the time comes
they put susan storm in the mcu if they
do it right
you will look at every single female
character that came before her and you
will be like they were paltry they all
fall before just susan storm because she
is a badass just in so many ways she's
absolutely amazing so i'm so it is this
is one of those things where it
legitimately does make sense the other
part of this is that as far as the plan
of dr doom went nightcrawler comes in
and starts teleporting uh apocalypse's
celestial armor off of him leaving him
vulnerable and in that moment the one
true weakness that apocalypse has more
than any other as far as earthbound
makes its presence known when dracula
bites into apocalypse and converts him
turns him into a vampire now this is 100
a plot device this is absolutely a plot
device here because the way this ends
questionable at best the way this ends
is that with apocalypse being bitten by
a vampire in essence tom taylor's like
the vampiric nature of dracula overtakes
the mutant physiology of apocalypse and
when that happens basically blade stabs
apocalypse in the chest with a wooden
spike and then cuts his head off and
that's the end of apocalypse and then
like everybody celebrates and magneto's
saved and then they they leave and
that's the story i told you guys the
ending was so rushed it was just like
apocalypse was dead game over and like
that's it right like nothing else about
the unmaker it's just left there down in
the core of the world i guess the
portals never close there's no there's
no epilogue no conclusion we never find
out what happens next it's just it ends
and that's the story so a phenomenal
story that just
fell flat at the end just
totally petered out at the end i loved
it up until the end like when i was
reading this i was like wait what like
no no there's got to be some kind of
epilogue like i was looking online i was
like is there an epilogue that i miss
right like i'm sorting through
comicsology and i'm like i'm googling or
looking up every single thing i'm doing
like google searches right because like
maybe some website out there knows about
some epilogue that i don't know about no
this is just it this is how it ends game
over story's done so with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end
[Laughter]
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace